دعونا نتعرف وبالارقام على القنوات الاكثر
ربحيه في عالم يوتيوب لعام 2022 وبحسب
موقع يوتيوب فان قناه كوكو ميلون تحتل
المركز الاول في قنوات يوتيوب العالمي
وحققت اكثر من مليار مشاهده فيما صاحبها
باربع مئه مليون دولار امريكي قناه
وتبلغ ارباحها نحو 200 مليون دولار كل عام
وهي متخصصه بمستحضرات التجميل والموسيقى
قناه ريان كاجي او عالم راين وهو طفل يبلغ
من العمر سبع سنوات يعمل في مقاتل العاب
وبرمجتها وتقدر ثروته باكثر من 100 مليون
دولار امريكي قناه مستر بيست وحد اشهر
مستخدمي يوتيوب يدوم اكثر من مليون مشترك
وصار متخصصا بمطاعم الوجبات السريعه واصبح
يمتلك سلسله منها لتقدر ثروته ب 100 مليون
دولار ايضا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات